joining us Now to respond house
oversight committee chairman James comr
and house ways and means committee
chairman Jason Smith gentlemen welcome
back appreciate
it all
right Jason let me let me start with you
tonight and you brought the
whistleblowers back in and we learned an
awful lot in the last 24 hours can you
bring everybody up to speed absolutely
Sean it's great to be with you we had a
7-hour hearing and the whistleblowers
provided over 56 pages of new
documentations President Biden has said
that he is not he has not known anything
about his son Hunter Biden's business
dealings well we have
327 emails that prove otherwise in fact
54 emails came from President Biden and
his fake Alias accounts to Hunter
Biden's business associate Eric scharen
who was the architect of all of the
shell corporations that Hunter Biden
used to pass millions of dollars
throughout uh through foreign entities
and then to a lot of his family members
uh let's talk about what are in these
emails and how does it specifically
implicate the president himself I mean
we know Hunter says that he gave half
his income to Pops we know he complained
bitterly about paying for pops's home
repairs uh we know you know that 10% was
set aside from the big guy um and we
also know the bribery statute does not
mandate that if he is Vice President
takes an action that benefits somebody
in his family that would be bribery by
law wouldn't
it it would be one of the emails that
that the whistleblowers uncovered was an
email from Kevin Morris to the tax
preparer of Hunter Biden's that that
said that they needed to take care of
Hunter Biden's uh tax problems which was
about $2 million at that time and said
if they didn't it would they would be
facing great personal and political risk
the political risk of that Sean was the
fact that it was three weeks before
super Tuesday in in February of 2020
that political risk was the election of
Joe Biden all right let me ask you James
comr both you and Jim Jordan on
Judiciary have now threaten to hold
Hunter Biden in contempt of congress and
I believe that includes Joe's brother
James Biden uh if they fail to show up
for the after the subpoena that you sent
them what actions will you take well we
how them in contempt I mean we've issued
lawful subpoenas uh I'm hopeful they'll
both show up I have more confidence that
Jim Biden's going to show up than I do
Hunter uh you're seeing today rhetoric
from the Democrats on the house
oversight committee uh openly
encouraging Hunter Biden not to show up
I mean the Democrats have OB the
Democrats on the oversight committee
have obstructed this credible
investigation just as much as the Biden
legal team just as much as the as the
mainstream media and and all these
government agencies who were supposed to
be investigating but we're GNA hold
Hunter Biden accountable if he doesn't
show up for the subpoena Sean we looked
and the and Donald Trump's immediate
family testified in depositions on the
January 6th committee for 18 hours 18
hours Donald Trump's family showed up
for depositions when they were
subpoenaed by the January 6
but the bidens think they're you know
the BW doesn't apply to them that that
they're special and they they aren't
going to show up I mean there's more
evidence now about Hunter Biden than
than most criminals that have to show up
for depositions in Big Time legal cases
so uh he's going to be there or we're
going to hold him accountable exit
question for both of you Jason Smith do
you believe that your committee and
chairman Comer's committee and chairman
Jordan's committee have now accumulated
enough evidence that at least on a prim
official level a case can be made that
Joe Biden was involved in bribery as
vice president that he took specific
official action in exchange for a
benefit financially for his family we
have over 1100 pages of documentation
that that's came from the two IRS
whistleblowers that came before the Ways
and Means Committee there's numerous
examples in those 1100 pages that show
that in fact Joe Biden had um had helped
his son um in in in a lot of business
dealings in fact from the sense of I
believe that they've used Air Force 2 um
more like a corporate jet flying his son
to Ukraine and Mexico um it's quite it's
quite disturbing of the official acts
that the whistleblowers have tied
into um instances of official conduct
and your same question James
mhm yeah look we had the F FBI 1023 form
that alleged bribery but yet the FBI
refused to investigate it now we find
there were more informant that accused
the bidens of accepting bribes and you
look at what happened with barisma with
firing the prosecutor shoken who was
investigating barisma that was a quidd
proquote remember the Democrats
impeached Donald Trump for asking about
Joe Biden's quid pro quo Joe Biden
committed the ultimate quid pro quo with
our tax dollars leveraging uh a billion
dollars of tax dollars to get a
prosecutor fired who was investigating
his son and then you look at what he's
done with China we believe he's
compromised because of the millions of
dollars he's taken from China and his
son continued to get paid didn't he all
right thank you both chairman comr and
chairman Smith we appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else